[Applause]
I did it, I'll report it to my mom right away Are you
surprised and
scared? What are you? What are you?
I ca
n't help but let's introduce myself
Prince of the Underworld Squirrel Kingdom
Tastypictunalis, a gorilla in the
middle of the battle Bonchon
Nikoli Lagisty Peach Unoris Surely it's a
surprise peach day, isn't it?
I
'm sorry I don't know
you I came to catch you and I caught
you Do you know what this means,
what does it mean?
Are they all your friends?
Are you scared?
If you're going to apologize, now's the time.
[Music]
Stop
it.  Hey,
if I catch you, what will you
do for me?
Oh yeah, I
'll execute them instead
No, they don't work to make people suffer,
rather the opposite,
immortality
[music]
Where are you going
?
Come on, both of you, but
keep the torch quiet, I've caught immortality